عقيده الردع النووي لا تزال قائمه في
سياسات الامنيه لجميع الدول التي لديها
اسلحه نوويه والعديد من حلفائها تقول
الامم المتحده يوجد 13
الفارب
وبالرغم من وقوع خفض كبير في الاسلحه
النوويه التي نشرت في الحرب البارده فانه
لم يدمر فعليا حتى راس النووي واحد
ستارت الثلاثه تعد اهم معاهده تحقق
التوازن الاستراتيجي بين القوتين
النوويتين الرئيسيتين في العالم روسيا
والولايات المتحده تنص المعاهده على تخفيض
الحد الاقصى للرؤوس الحربيه الهجوميه
الاستراتيجيه للبلدين بنسبه الثلاثين في
المئه ولاليات الاطلاق الاستراتيجي بنسبه
خمسين في المئه
[موسيقى]
كما تنص على ان يخفض الطرفان ترسانته من
النوويه خلال السبع سنوات الى 700 صاروخ
باليسي عابر للقارات وهذا النوع من
الصواريخ قادر على حمل رؤوس الحربيه
كالقنابل او المتفجرات او الرؤوس النوويه
ويتحرك في مسار على شكل قوس من نقطه الى
اخرى
حاولت روسيا في عام 2020 اقناع اداره
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالدخول في مفاورات لتمديد المعاهده او
اعداد صيغه اخرى جديده لها اصرار واشنطن
على ادراج الصين في المفاوضات لتكون جزءا
من معاهده جديده شكل عائقا امام التوصل
الى اي قرار من النقاط الخلافيه الاخرى
اعتراض واشنطن على تطوير روسيا صواريخ
متطوره تفوق سرعتها تسع مرات سرعه الصوت
وهذا النوع من الصواريخ الباريسيه هو
الاكثر تطورا في العالم ويعتمد على
التحليق في الطبقات العليا من الغلاف
الجوي اعلى من الصواريخ الباليستيه
التقليديه ثم ينفصل عنها الراس الحربي
بسرعه هائله نحو مستويات ادنى الى الاهداف
المحدده في عام
دمرت قنبلتان نوويت ان مدينتي هيروشيما
ونكز في اليابانيتين
وتشير التقديراته الى قتلهما على الفور ما
مجموعه
213 الف شخص وبعد مرور اكثر من 75 عاما
على هذه الكارثه النوويه اتفقت القوتان
نويتان رئيسيتان في العالم روسيا
والولايات المتحده على تمديد معاهده
السارت ثلاثه لخمس سنوات اخرى دون ادراج
اي تعديل عليها